if you don't think i go and smoke a big
one every now and again i got my own
banana more if you know what i mean
[Applause]
ladies and gentlemen it's mitzi
bananamore coming to you from the button
club
i'm here with none other than michael
zeegan
who also is joel mazel and many other
characters in fact you were a dwight
and uh letterman i was dwight the
troubled teen you know why french kiss
david letterman
uh
i didn't know that
i know uh the character you want to play
the most is uh groucho marx is that
correct yeah i think i said that uh once
or twice yeah
and why do you want to play groucho mark
there hasn't been a movie uh made about
groucho or the marx brothers that i know
of i don't know as much as i used to
know about them oh you're gonna work on
it i think i suggest you do a little
homework really stunning
um i swear i used to know a great deal
about it and it's just the years have
kind of you know wore down on my brain a
little bit a little too much of this you
might not get too much of that if you
know but by the way how else are you
gonna laugh you had a sketch comedy
group called the the hotties galore
hotties
with the s being a money sign yeah tell
me about that well i yeah i wasn't
prepared to talk about that but sure uh
i guess you you really did your research
well um
like you with groud show yeah
hotties galore was uh with the dollar
sign with the dollars trying to you know
well we were trying to separate our and
like round no this this was a two live
crew kind of a thing
no
this was pre-twerking
and uh i think we were just kind of
trying to
differentiate ourselves from the other
hotties galore that you might find when
you look up hotties galore on on the
internet uh so hey internet porn oh that
ruined society it was just a bunch of
friends and uh you know we graduated
college we were doing sketch comedy in
college and then we came to the city and
started doing it here and we would rent
out a theater space and have a weekend
of shows and it was great it was really
fun now uh is it true that you use a
noise machine to fall asleep
what is going on here yeah uh
yes
yes i do well honey you and i would be
great bed buddies because i cannot sleep
without a fan on to save my life yeah i
start
nitpicking every noise i hear i'm like
at scratching at the wall i need a
and none of this modern stuff with like
a forest you know then i'll just keep
waiting for the next
like monkey and no no no i need
not even a beach nothing i need no i'm
gonna wait for the next wave i need that
white noise now i also love hold on i
got my notes here
my papers aren't as good as they used to
be you started acting when you were five
right
not professionally but uh
yeah i mean that's it was it was my
my dream since i was five i'd say did
you think that it was playing a
character or make believe or pretend
that
really did it for you
and was there a moment where you made
someone laugh and it gave you a certain
feeling i did this production of annie
with all these kids my age and i was i
was rooster and i remember coming out
onto onto the stage and my grandfather
was sitting in like the second row and i
just i i you know
zoned in on him and and i saw he had
this big smile and he was laughing and
uh it was i mean that was it and that's
the exact thing i'm looking for in that
question that's what i'm digging for
because i think when you see
that you
sparkle someone that that they respond
to you there's like a comedic velcro
feeling like two puzzle pieces coming
together when i see someone laugh i
don't care it's because i just hurt the
[ __ ] out of myself or because i said
something funny or someone died you know
whatever it is
as long as it's a laugh it's a great
coping mechanism in life you know also i
grew up in the 80s and there were a lot
of movies during the 80s that i think
were geared towards kids you had you
know the goonies you had stand by me
um
e.t
i don't know if you've uh seen that yeah
no
what makes you laugh
what makes me laugh yeah write out loud
lol you make me laugh
yeah
they can don't tease the animals dumb
and dumber oh
um dumb and dumber's a masterpiece
uh citizen kane
dumb and dumber yeah
you want to sit around and watch citizen
kane hung over on a sunday
all right is there a a comedian that
makes you laugh harder than anyone i i
was always such a big fan of robin
williams he was he was always my
favorite when i hosted saturday night
live in 1982 steven spielberg brought
him as a guest oh yeah yeah and the two
of them watched i was like oh my god i
got to do this in front of mork i was
terrified
i like it i like it a lot you know what
i also like i like a spit take and i'm
wondering if i can put some liquid in my
mouth and see if you can make me spit it
out you ready for it
um knock knock
[Laughter]
okay let's skip to the next one
okay what's a foot long and slippery
a slipper
okay
one second how does uh how does a rabbi
make coffee
he brews
it he brews it oh that's some borscht
belt humor i love it good the food is so
awful yeah in such small portions it's
the best
michael ziegan long time fan first time
caller well thank you thank you same
what up zegan oh yes okay
[Music]
you